- How does southeastern Wisconsin fit
into this national election picture?
- I mean it's battle ground zero, right?
We've always been a battleground but,
always at the end of these elections,
it seems to have faded away
and other States have become more focused.
I think Wisconsin is a great place
and I think that even
when we have differences,
we can a have a beer and a brat, right?
- [Narrator] Roughly half
of America's voters live
in the suburbs,
and in the final months of the campaign,
as president Trump seeks
to boost his support
in those communities,
he has zeroed in on the
threat of violent crime.
- The suburbs are coming big to us
because the suburbs are next.
If you elected this guy,
the suburbs would be overwhelmed
with violence and crime.
[Narrator] And Wisconsin, a swing state,
is likely to be some of the
most fought over ground.
In 2016, President Trump won here by fewer
than 23,000 votes.
- [News Anchor] He will win Wisconsin,
with its 10 electoral votes
he's cracked the so called, "Blue wall"
- [Narrator] A Marquette Law School poll
of likely Wisconsin voters
from early September showed
former vice president Joe Biden
leading president Trump 47% to 43%.
Three suburban counties
around Milwaukee serve
as a GOP counterweight
to the traditionally large
democratic margins recorded
in the State's two largest
cities, Milwaukee and Madison.
The president will likely need to win big
in the suburban counties
if he wants to take the state again.
We sat down with a group of voters
from Waukesha and Ozaukee counties,
half voted for Trump and half
voted for Clinton in 2016,
to discuss the coronavirus
pandemic, the economy, policing
and how they are weighing a
sudden supreme court vacancy,
as they think about November's election.
- Did anybody really sort of struggle
with that decision in 2016?
- I actually voted
Republican in 2008, in 2012
and then in 2016, I voted
Democrat for the first time,
in my case was because of the
person instead of the party.
I couldn't vote for Donald Trump.
- Raise your hands if you plan
to vote for president Trump
between now and November.
And who plans to vote for Joe Biden?
Sabrina it seemed like your hand raise
on Joe Biden was a little bit lukewarm.
- Yes, I do want him to
show up more strongly
on some issues so I'm
still listening closely.
- He might not get your vote?
- It's completely possible, yes.
- On Memorial Day weekend
George Floyd was killed
in Minneapolis neighboring
state to Wisconsin,
and then subsequently in the summer,
another man was shot in Kenosha by police.
I wanna get your sense for sort
of the Black Lives Matter movement,
there's been calls for police reform,
it's obviously a challenging topic
to talk about race in America,
but let's try to talk
about it a little bit
and see where you're feeling in terms
of how these protests have gone,
sometimes they've moved into riots
and what you think should be
done in terms of police reform.
- There's over 700,000 law enforcement
in the country right now
that we can expect those human
beings in those situations,
those conditions with that responsibility
to act flawlessly as ridiculous.
And one is even more childish is to think
that we can improve that
by reducing the amount
of law enforcement.
It's super unfortunate
that there are situations
like Floyd that do arise,
but when it comes to the numbers
itself and the interaction
and the people we're dealing
with, they are people,
yeah, there could be a little
bit more reform in terms
of making people
accountable for their jobs
in the proper way and
making sure they're not
on the force if they're not capable.
- Sabrina, you've talked a little bit
about the segregation that
exists in this metropolitan area.
What is your take?
- It would be hypocritical
to be an American per se
and not understand that we have a history
of violence in this country.
Unfortunately, change has
come through violence.
It's not the way that I want it to be.
I'd love to come to the table
and talk it out and
just get rid of the ills
of our country but
that's not what happened.
So understanding that racism
has seeped into so many parts
of our country, just it's as
American as apple pie, right?
There has to be reform within healthcare,
there has to be reformed within housing,
there has to be reformed within
the criminal justice system,
there has to be reformed in immigration.
We have all these areas that
we have to dismantle racism
and become aware of our unconscious
bias and choose justice.
- When they talk about,
well only a few people have
been shot or killed or whatever,
that's just the tip of the iceberg.
It's really a lot more
than just a few bad apples.
It's really systematic.
I do feel that Trump
really incites the violence
and incites the divisiveness
and incites on the hate.
- The root of the problem
is systemic racism.
We can't just turn a blind eye and say,
oh, you know, everything's fine.
And it starts with
opportunities and the economy.
Like you said we have a segregated city.
Look at the resources we're
providing to the South side
and the North side of Milwaukee
versus a predominantly
white area like Brookfield
and Waukesha County,
the resources are day and night.
How do we expect people to be okay?
- Sue your turn.
What's are your observations
about the summer of unrest
that took place in this country?
Well, I guess I don't understand
why people think it's Trump's fault
that all this is going on.
I was always taught as
a young child growing up
that if a police officer tells
you to stop, you stopped.
I don't care what color you are,
black, white, yellow, or purple.
These people deal with
people that are on drugs,
people that are crazy and
so I could see how some
of these police officers are nudge,
now we have some of them
taking it way too far?
Yes, they do believe so.
And I'm not saying they were right
in what I think is torturing George Floyd.
That certainly is not right
but there needs to be a little bit
of acceptance on both sides
that both sides did wrong.
- Tamir Rice was shot
before he had any chance
to respond to any kind of police order.
So the narrative that people
aren't following directions,
isn't completely true unfortunately
I've had police approached me
when their hands are
literally on their weapon
if they're coming up to me,
and my kids are right there seeing this.
So it's not that folks
are necessarily attempting
to not listen to police,
I think that narrative has to go.
- My father is a retired police officer.
So I have the utmost respect for police.
And I think our big problem too is a lot
of the words we use,
the terminology, defund the
police, that's a bad term.
I wish nobody had put that term out there.
It's not about taking away money
or taking away police officers.
It's really, most of us want,
we want better education
for police officers,
we want more support for them,
social workers coming in
on some of these calls.
- Sabrina, can you just talk a little bit
about your vote and how you are feeling
about former vice president Joe Biden?
- I do feel like Joe Biden
recently he started a campaign
or at least his team started a campaign
of being more harsh on the variety.
When I think about Philando Castile
and being murdered in Minnesota,
and then I think about what happened
with George Floyd being
murdered in Minnesota,
again same place, same kind of injustice
but there wasn't really change
or a movement until
George Floyd was murdered
and the public had an
uprising, same state.
So people don't listen until
things get out of hand per se.
So I really don't like the
messaging of Joe Biden.
I do want him to stand with
the fact that there's injustice
that needs to be fixed.
There are people being crushed
underneath these systems
and they are Americans also.
And when we say defund the
police, we definitely mean it.
I don't wanna lose that message either,
we do mean defund the police
- We do
- Because we want systems that
actually do support people
in the ways that policing can not.
- We're sitting down just
days after the passing
of Ruth Bader Ginsburg leaving a seat open
on the Supreme court.
How many of you think
that seat should be filled still
during Donald Trump's first term?
- Well, obviously we have a constitution,
it's by the advice and
consent of the Senate.
The Senate is Republican.
If the president wants
to put forward his
nominee he has his right.
He's still the until January.
- Well, I agree with
Chris, I'm gonna qualify it
though there's one thing
that concerns me the most
is what implications will be
on the election if in
fact that president Trump
and the Senate goes forward
with the nomination.
I'd hate to think
that pushing this forward would
put president Trump's re-election at risk
or some of the senators
that are up for reelection.
- Sabrina talk a little bit
about why you don't think it
should be filled this year.
- Just looking at the
last example of the way
that Republicans stood up and said no,
Barack Obama cannot bring
somebody into this role
when he had more time than this one,
then I would say the same thing.
- Lets pivot to a subject
that really has dominated obviously all
of our lives practically all
year, and that's the pandemic.
How many of you routinely
wear a mask when you go out
in public pretty much anywhere?
- Well it depends.
I mean if some place where I
know there's gonna be a lot
of people that of course
I will wear a mask,
but if I'm taking my dogs
for a walk by myself,
I'm not gonna put a mask on.
- Well, again, it goes back
to the inconsistent messaging
about the effectiveness of mask.
There is this like a
virtual signaling issue
with mask out there at this point as well.
It does come down to sort
of what are our rights as citizens?
- The president has talked
about having a vaccine potentially
in time for the election.
What do you all think of about,
who do you believe when
it comes to the vaccine?
- So to try to get a vaccine
out and mask produced
and available in a matter of weeks
or months it's not
possible, it's not safe.
- Who all do you listen to
in terms of trusting what
to know about the vaccine?
Who do you trust in terms of that topic?
- I think it was hard
when the CDC came out
or somebody came out and originally said,
mask don't help , don't use masks.
and that made it really hard
for a lot of people to trust.
But I think we didn't
know what we didn't know
and we shouldn't have assumed
that we knew something.
I definitely I still
listen to file sheets,
I try to trust the CDC.
I think unfortunately they've
been influenced politically
when they shouldn't be,
but I think they're
still a reputable source.
- Chris who do you trust in on this topic?
- Well, it's what's stunning
to me I think is doctors are
starting to sound like lawyers.
There's a lot of different
opinions and none of them seem
to agree which always worries me.
My nephew was just diagnosed with COVID,
asymptomatic no issues.
I have two assistants,
one of my assistants got COVID.
So it's affected me personally
but I'm not sure who
to believe on it
- Is there anybody on the panel lost a job
or significant piece of income
because of the pandemic?
- So I own a private
practice optometric practice,
and so we were forced to close.
So I ended up having to
lay off my entire staff.
- Are you open again?
- Yeah.
- Give me your sense
for how you think president Trump
has handled this situation.
- I think he's done a good job
as far as letting the states
determine each individual state
on how they wanna handle it because
when New York was being so
burdened, Wisconsin had nothing.
- We can't blame Trump
for the virus of course.
And I don't even really blame him
for his initial actions or inactions
but I think now, especially
six months plus later,
they are holding and having these rallies,
political rallies with hundreds of people,
or sometimes even thousands in
a closed space without masks
and him continuing to attack people
or make fun of people who wear
masks including Joe Biden.
I think to me that is probably
what bothers me the most.
- And we should not have this many people
in the United States who died from this.
So the response was not quick enough.
It was not to the degree
that it should have been.
And they had disproportionate outcomes
for different communities.
There's more black folks
who have died from this.
There are more Latinos
who are dying from this.
This is not fair.
- How about your local
and state officials?
Do you feel like they've done a better
or worse job than
Washington on this issue?
- It's very inconsistent
which creates confusion.
We literally have school
districts within Ozaki County
that have different policies
about how they're handling
kids going back to school.
What makes Port Washington
different from Macon?
- You have the liberal areas
saying science shut down,
forget the economy, everyone's dying.
Conservative areas are saying open it up,
we got to have an economy freedom
and those neighborhoods are
very close to each other.
So it's kind of like within
five minutes you can be
in three different zones of opinion.
I generally follow the policy
of what my client wants.
So when my client shows up
in a mask, I put on a mask.
If my client asks me to
take it off, I take it off.
- Everybody has since agreed
everything has been politicized.
When I see clients, I wear a mask,
My clients wear a mask in my office.
I have a hand sanitizer,
not because I'm afraid, I'd
rather be in on the safe side,
why take a chance?
Why would I wanna be responsible
of infecting somebody
and that person potentially
could die because
of how I do things?
I definitely don't want
the economy shut down,
I wanna see customers, I
wanna take care of them.
I'll see them in my
office anytime, any day,
but with the proper precaution.
- The economy and the pandemic
are very much intertwined.
Chris talk a little bit about
your real estate business
and what you've seen.
- When the pandemic
started I was very nervous
and braced for the worst.
The real estate economy which
to me has always been an indicator,
obviously for me personally
it's my business,
has been amazing.
- Raise your hand
if you thought the economy was pretty good
in January and February.
Everybody else has their
hands up other than Sabrina,
she's still kind of not sure
that the economy was that great.
Now raise your hand
again if you're satisfied
with the economy as it is today.
- I think so many people I feel look
at the stock market as the economy
or what you're seeing your 401k,
but when you look at Milwaukee,
it's kind of like inequities
the average suburban
or those of us in these counties,
maybe our economy or whatever is fine,
but when you look at the city
of Milwaukee in certain areas,
I don't think our economy is fine.
- Bernie you work with
a lot of immigrants.
What's your take on sort of
how new immigrants are doing
in the economy right now?
- Definitely not doing very well
because well number one,
a lot of the immigrants didn't qualify
for these stimulus checks.
So overall a lot
of the huge Latino community
is impacted negativity.
- Sue what is your sense
as a business owner just
for the economy sort
of writ large in your area?
- The economy, yes Is coming back.
Is it back 100% in certain fields?
I believe it is,
but certain fields it is
nowhere near a hundred percent.
You start having people lose their jobs
then they lose their insurance.
It's all a chain reaction
or a trickle down effect.
If we don't save our economy,
it's gonna affect many many more lives
than this pandemic will.
So I do believe that we
need to be very protective
of our economy and get things moving.
Yes, do it safely, but
we cannot just keep,
we can't all lock ourselves
in and shut everything down.
It's just going to be a disaster
- We've gleaned tonight that
there's there's division here
in the suburbs of Milwaukee,
differing opinions not unlike
the rest of the country.
Some of you have who have lived
in the area for longer times.
Can you just talk about
how the area is changing
and sort of if you sense
more political division
as the area has diversified?
- This community was
always very Republican
and now there's Biden signs out there.
I think it's very divided
within neighborhoods,
which we've never seen before.
- Other than when I was serving
in different duty stations
I've always came back to Waukesha
and I've been through 89.
At that time, there was a
very few Latino families.
It's grown tremendously over the years.
Traditionally, the
Latinos vote more Democrat
- Being aware of the history
of Wisconsin and the red lining
that caused these suburbs to stay so white
and how those barriers
are starting to be removed
and allowing people to move
out into areas really allows
for a diversity to exist.
And I do appreciate the fact
that there's different voices
to speak to different
people who are available.
I do like different ideas.
- The question isn't necessarily
whether Trump will win
these suburban Milwaukee
counties probably will,
but it'll depend on how much
margin he gets and then how
that affects the overall statewide
totals here in Wisconsin.
What do you guys think?
- I feel a lot of
leadership pushing people
to register and to vote and
if we get everybody coming out
and we increase the voting,
we already got a Democrat
governor last time.
So we actually I think that is going blue
and I see that trend.
So as long as people get out and vote,
I think that Trump will lose in the state.
- Chris what's gonna happen in Wisconsin?
- I think Trump will do
very well in Waukesha County
and Washington County,
Ozaki County is the one
that is I think the closest.
The question will there
be enough votes rural
in rural Wisconsin to
offset the huge turnout
in Madison and Milwaukee
and that's usually the game.
I think Trump will win
and I'm counting on it.
I'm nervous, but I'm hopeful.
(soft music)